(electronic bell chiming)
- Happy Hanukkah!
- Happy Chanukkah!
- Oh, you say it with a C?
- Oh, BB I add the C.
C is for (beeps).
- Wow.
Okay, you open yours first.
- No, c'mon you
open yours first.
- No, you go first.
- Dude, please open
your gift first.
- Okay, I can't say
no to that face.
Okay.
Five, four, three, two, one.
- [Abbi] Hanukkah day.
(gasps)
- Oh my god, a slow cooker!
Are you serious?!
This is high, high quality.
- You like it?
- I don't like it, bitch.
I love it!
- Yes!
- I'm gonna marinate
meat for hours and hours
and hours and hours
all the live long day.
I really appreciate
it, thank you so much.
Okay, now it's your turn.
- Here we go.
- You are going to love it.
Do you love it?!
- Yes, yes, I do.
I mean, I love it.
- I was just like what
do you get the girl
who already has everything,
and this just
popped into my head.
- This did?
- Mm-hm.
It doesn't come with batteries,
so I wrapped some in
tobacco leaves for you.
They're also in there.
There they are.
And there's a sample of
water-based cleanser.
Do not wash it with soap,
it will deteriorate
and start to peel.
- I wouldn't have
thought to like wash it.
- Huh.
- I will follow
those instructions
to take good care of this.
Oh my god, dude,
I'm running late.
I gotta go.
- [Ilana] Okay, love you, BB.
- Love you.
- Happy Chanukkah.
- You too.
Thanks for my thing.
Ew!
(electronic bells chiming)